aujourd'hui je reçois une nouvelle
invitée qui vient nous parler de sa
particularité bien à elle il s'agit de
madame aude gg non mais regardez la
vidéo vous allez comprendre
aude côté là c'est moi c'est hot money
goubert dit au djé djé et comédienne
metteuse en scène et youtube
elle a travaillé à la comédie française
avec le palmashow golden moustache et
sur sa chaîne youtube au djé djé projet
virago odjé bonjour bonjour alors
qu'elle est à particularité ma
particularité et la prosopagnosie est ce
que tu peux nous expliquer en deux mots
en quoi ça consiste en deux mois je ne
reconnais pas les visages il me faut une
20 à 30 fois pour identifier
formellement quelqu'un est encore
parfois ça peut prendre plus de temps
creusot paguenaud dit ça vient du grec
prose au pont qui veut dire visage et
que novice la connaissance précédé du a
privatif c'est donc littéralement
l'incapacité à reconnaître les visages
au quotidien c'est donc un enfer 1
alors nouveau que disons qu'en fait les
spurs il ya encore ces jeux à la
télévision le matin où on déplace un peu
les cases comme dans un puzzle et il
s'appelle johnny
c'est un chanteur de rock retrouver son
voile à l'étude doit reconstituer les
cases
eh ben pour moi c'est comme ça un visage
c'est comme des gros pixels qui se
seraient déplacées du fait que je n'ai
pas une vision globale d'un visage donc
au quotidien je dis bonjour aux gens
sans savoir si je les connais si je les
ai déjà vus
si je suis censé les connaître voilà
donc je développe tout un tas de petits
stratagèmes pour les rencontres et leur
dire bonjour mais c'est très compliqué
au quotidien il m'arrive même parfois
des gens que je connais très bien si je
les vois hors contexte et que je ne
m'attends pas à les voir je peux ne peut
vraiment passer à côté sans les sans les
identifier la prosopagnosie que m
congénital
dans ces cas là ce qui se passe ces
concours de son développement la
personne l'intègre pas les étapes
nécessaires d'analystes des traits et de
reconnaissance des visages comme la
dyslexie
tu te souviens à quel moment tu t'es
rendu compte que tu avais 7
prosopagnosie ça fait longtemps que je
chargeais je peux pas identifier un
moment précis ça fait longtemps que j'ai
vraiment un problème de reconnaissance
des visages et souvent je me dis je me
suis dit je n'étais pas attentive que
c'était que c'était ma faute que maman
je t'aurais plus me concentrer et en
fait c'est fabien olicard quand même une
bonne connaissance des méandres du
cerveau humain qui m'a dit un jour en
voyant que j'étais complètement en black
out devant des gens qu'on était censé
connaître m'a dit mais tu sais tu
devrais être penché sur la prosopagnosie
et il ya un livre qui explique bien ça
qui s'appelle l'homme qui prenait sa
femme pour un chapeau c'est oliver sacks
qui était un neuroscientifique qui a
parlé de sa propre peau prosopagnosie
d'ailleurs et et alors les stades
peuvent être différentes ce qui a
vraiment des gens qui en l'occurrence la
ja vers le cas où il voyait un chapeau
et il lui parlait comme si c'était sa
femme donc ça c'est un stade que je n'ai
pas encore at home dieu merci
et donc quand on fabien olicard m'a dit
tu devrais tu devrais te pencher là
dessus et bien tout un monde s'est
ouvert à moi c'était il ya c'est un 3 4
ans et là j'ai découvert en fait que
j'avais
vraie raison de ne pas reconnaître les
gens que j'étais pas tout seul puisqu'il
y en a qui s'est très peu connu mais il
ya quelques personnes identifiées qui en
parlent beaucoup comme brad pitt
philippe vandel natacha polony
c'est des gens qui sont identifiés
prosopagnosie kaki du coup et c'est de
faire connaître
j'allais dire la maladie en même temps
c'est oui c'est une maladie c'est une
déficience cognitive et du coup c'est
vrai que en en parlant avec eux mais en
fait on se rend compte qu'on a les mêmes
bugs une vraie bête des vraies voix le
voile blanc devant les yeux par le fait
de mettre un nom du coup sûr
le trouble que tu avais plus ou moins
identifiés c'est quelque chose qui va
plutôt inquiété ou quelque chose qui t'a
plutôt rassuré à moi ça m'a soulagé mais
incroyablement certes de voir même que
je pouvais non seulement identifié
plusieurs stades en plus me reconnaître
dans des témoignages
ça m'a soulagé parce qu'en plus entre
guillemets ça me déculpabiliser ou au
moins ça me donne une explication pour
les gens qui que je ne reconnais pas
après plusieurs fois et qui se vexe très
régulièrement alors les gens croient par
en général mais au moins je le dis et
parfois quand je rencontre une personne
avec qui je me suis bien entendu je lui
dis au fait je te préviens la prochaine
fois peut-être que je ne vais pas te
reconnaître et je préviens avant ça me
permet au moins de six ne me
déculpabiliser au moins de me soulager
un peu et tu dis parfois les gens se
vexer koala qui te crois pas la réaction
la plus fréquente chez les gens quand tu
leur quand tu leur expliques ce que ce
que tu as c'est quoi bah la réaction la
plus fréquente c'est ouais c'est ça tu
te sois tu t'intéresses pas aux gens
soient oui bah oui bien sûr maintenant
que tu es comédienne tu vois plein de
gens alors tu reconnais personne et
c'est pas le cas parce que vraiment pour
le coup comme j'ai développé d'autres
stratagèmes pour me souvenir des gens
souvent j'ai besoin des noms de famille
je déteste quand on se présente en me
disant juste un prénom parce que du coup
je sais qu'il ya rien qui va vraiment me
fixer sur quelque chose j'aime bien
avoir le nom de famille mais alors il ya
un truc très bête et ça j'ai passé mon
cerveau qui fait ça c'est que je vais
m'accrocher un détail par exemple je
sais exactement entre regardant dans les
yeux ce qui a écrit sur son tee shirt
je me vois exactement ta bague qui est
très particulière avec un oeil et dont
la voilà je vais je vais bloqués sur des
choses comme ça ce qui fait qu'au cours
d'une soirée
je vais retombées sur la personne je
vais savoir qui elle est d'accord sauf
qu'il s'agit suffit que la personne
enlève son sweat nous enlève ses jeans
et bas dans la même soirée je peux ne
pas y faire attention
donc du coup c'est un peu bête de
s'accrocher aux fringues mais ce qui
peut m'aider souvent c'est les paires de
lunettes très marqués ou une capillarité
hors du commun
c'est voir ce qui était que je t'oublie
pas jamais mais voilà donc du coup je me
raccroche à d'autres choses qui montrent
que ce n'est pas un désintérêt pour les
gens mais c'est juste qu'il faut que je
développe d'autres moyens de m'en
souvenir
ouais c'est un peu comme tous les gens
qui ont une déficience soit d'un sens
soit d'une fonction tu développes tu sûr
développe les autres pour rappel d un
petit peu sauf qu'évidemment une
personne que je reprends avec j'ai vu 15
fois et qui ne porte pas les mêmes
lunettes et qui ne dit pas son nom de
famille immédiatement il ya toujours ce
moment de malaise selon malentendus et
après jeudi
s'il dit je suis bruno dubois je vais
bien sûr 5e b voilà je peux tout lu
retracer tout ce qu'on a vécu ensemble
et toute sa vie sauf que s'il me dit pas
ça donc ça ça fait que quand je dis
bonjour à quelqu'un je développe des
petites techniques souvent jeu j'attends
shell bonjour et j'attends si on me dira
le postillon dit le prénom je me dis ok
la personne considère qu'on ne se
connaît pas donc je dis mon prénom
sinon je ne dis plus rien
parce que la plupart du temps en fait
comme je viens toujours en présentant
dans bonjour aude les jambes
bah oui on se connaît avec l'ami je suis
ton père et ta pas des petites questions
petite question un peu un peu fourbe que
tu te poses pour savoir si d'une manière
ou d'une autre a déjà croisé les gens
non parce qu'en fait en vrai le moment
de la rencontre est toujours tellement
une source d'angoissé serre que quoi
qu'il arrive ça monte je le dis bon
c'est le crash test permanent en fait
c'est toujours à ce moment là alors par
exemple quand je sais que je vais dans
une soirée où sur un tournage je lis
tout la feuille de service avec toute
l'équipe
comme ça je sais si je connais déjà des
noms et si j'ai déjà vu ce qui fait que
je suis pas surprise quand je les vois
et donc dans le contexte je sais pas
voilà je me prépare avant d'aller dans
un endroit remise en aura peut-être
telle personne n'ira peut-être telle
personne qui me permet de recoller les
morceaux quand je les trois ont
justement d'entrer dans ta vie que ce
soit perso ou professionnel c'est c'est
vraiment quelque chose que tu définirais
comme un handicap en os et hyper
handicapant parce que soit je vais je
vais être très jovial avec les gens qui
vont se dire bah elle est vraiment super
sympa et vraiment elle me reconnais pas
donc qu'elle est sympa avec la terre
entière sauf avec moi soit je vais avoir
peur de la gaffe donc je vais t'en avoir
tendance à me renfermer sur moi même et
à ne pas oser aller vers les gens donc à
passer un peu pour la fille qui
s'intéresse pas qui vient pas alors que
non c'est plus un c'est quand je suis
dans un lieu public ou que je vais seul
à un spectacle potentiellement il ya des
gens que je connais mais du coup j'ai
tendance à être sur mon téléphone ou
être un peu me mettre dans une petite
bulle parce que j'ai pas envie de
ressentir le malaise des pas reconnaître
quelqu'un et en plus comme il ya des
gens qui m'ont déjà vu à la télé ou sur
le web
j'ai déjà un but qui peuvent qu il
sourit et du coup bah ça m'arrive quand
on me souhaite faire salut ça va
et la personne vraiment ne me connaît
pas donc il se dit elle est vraiment
extrêmement jovial autres le truc c'est
horrible parce que voilà c'est ma vie
est plus grand avec le avec le temps tu
as l'impression que tu le vis de mieux
en mieux ou tu as l'impression que
finalement ça ça reste compliqué ça
reste compliqué mais je fais plus
attention
donc je sais que je fais d'autant plus
d'efforts pour essayer d'emmagasiner le
maximum de personnes
mais effectivement plus on avance en âge
plus on rencontre des gens plus on bouge
plus on donc ça donc le problème de
toutes façons de stack de paille les
volumes
je sais pas exactement à quel endroit du
cerveau tous à ceux effectués mais je
sais que à des moments d'intense fatigue
ça peut vraiment s'accentue est ce à
dire que je peux prendre un ami pour un
autre vraiment des gens qu'il connaît
très bien je peux dire bah je pensais
que tu étais au chili en voyage
humanitaire
le no 10 comment ces vierges et voilà ça
ou alors mais je sais pas si ça a
quelque chose à voir mais il ya n'ya pas
longtemps j'ai vu un épisode de
dissociation du cerveau donc je sais pas
si c'est lié ou pas du tout ça se veut
pour moi c'est lui parce que c'est cette
même sensation de bugs et d'avoir
j'étais avec un mais à mes partenaires
de jeu qui est on est en train de se
changer en loge et j'ai vu ces gens mais
c'est un partenaire masculin les gens
extrêmement poilus et j'ai bloqué un
temps mais je peux pas y aller comme ça
je suis pas du tout épiler mais vraiment
c'est à dire que sincèrement je la mets
qu'il faut que je m'épile et en fait
j'ai j'ai dissocier dans mon cerveau et
c'est s&s et j'ai cru que c'était ce que
c'était mes jambes donc il a fallu
vraiment que je me concentre près de 30
secondes non aude tuer la personne et là
c'est quelqu'un d'autre
enfin voilà donc je sais pas du tout si
c'est lié à mon avis ça va des frissons
de ronald vidéo est plus ou moins
cuisine ou en tout cas très potes qui
font que je sens que la
la la ça dégénère un peu ce que tu sais
s'il ya d'autres façons de gérer ce
genre de soucis ben je sais que philippe
vandel il il en parle beaucoup en
interview il fait de faire des articles
dessus extérieur donc ça m'a pas mal
aidé quand je les ai rencontrés de nous
donner se donner des petites techniques
et c'est vrai que lui il
il écrit dans son téléphone la personne
qui vient de rencontrer ils écrivent
donc il met le contact et il met des
détails en fait dans le téléphone ce qui
fait quand on lui parle de quelqu'un qui
regarde et celle ci l'a déjà rencontré
que c'est après ça n'aide pas sur la
reconnaissance faciale qui nous faudrait
c'est un bon shazam des gens je pense
que le shazam des gens de le développer
s'il vous plaît faites mais ce mot après
ça restera toujours gênant de venir voir
une personne faire excuser
oui c'est aux non mais tu sais vraiment
d'accoucher cinq ans ensemble sur une
photo ça va être pas si l'état des
rentes rombi non même en photo si tu as
non pas du tout puis alors en plus j'ai
l'impression que les gens c'est face c
c'est à dire que je peux voir des faits
des photos qui ont même cinq ans dix ans
par des gens avec qui j'ai passé
énormément de temps et ne pas du tout
savoir qu'ils sont mais rien ne leur
revient sûr que le visage pour moi c'est
un sermon c'est un truc un peu comme un
truc qu'on aurait estompé tu vois un
truc un peu fade fade tout blanc qu'on
aurait estompée et si vraiment et c'est
horrible parce que si quelqu'un n'a pas
une particularité physique je vais pas
dire que c'est quelqu'un de leur mandat
les châssis quelqu'un a pas un truc
vraiment marquants ça va être difficile
pour moi de l'accrocher mémoire pour moi
c'est comme un muscle et je pense
qu'elle s'entraîne en tant que
comédienne moi je peux apprendre
développer des flopées de texte et le ma
mémoire ne me fait pas défaut à cet
endroit là parce qu'elle et surentraînés
donc je pense que peut-être il faut
travailler d'autant plus à saison voilà
mais il n'y a pas de traitement n'y a
pas de vrai mais je m'aime moi même je
ne connais pas la cause
devin prosopagnosie la maladie peut
aussi être causée par des lésions
cérébrales après un avc un traumatisme
une tumeur ou une opération par exemple
dans ces cas là les zones cérébrales
touchées se situent à l'arrière au
niveau du lobe occipital et sur le côté
au niveau du lobe temporal
c'est à cet endroit que se situe le
gyrus fusiforme responsable de la
reconnaissance des visages
le fait d'avoir quelque chose qui te
rend différente des autres
est ce que c'est quelque chose que tu as
eu du mal à accepter est ce que c'est
quelque chose que tu vis mal ou est-ce
que tu me dis bah non je trouve que
c'est plutôt bon bien pouvoir
l'identifier après le problème c'est
quand les gens ne travaillent donc c'est
plutôt ça c'est à dire que moi
maintenant je suis ok avec ça j'avais
même les i terme anglais me faire un
badge je suis prosopagnosie quai quand
les gens me croient pas vraiment j'en ai
fait un badge j'ai pas fait ça mais
c'était une bonne solution
moi maintenant vous voilà je vis avec et
j'essaie de je sais que je peux pas
faire autrement
par contre c'est vraiment faire accepter
ce que l'argent parce que de toute façon
quand tu leur dis quand même qu'il soit
vexé ou pas quand tu leur a expliqué
tous les tenants et les aboutissants il
ya toujours une petite suspicion de ou
ou et enfin tu dis ça parce que voilà
parce que tu te sens m 2 pas voir
reconnue voilà mais je sais qu'il ya des
gens qui se vexe de toute façon donc je
vais pas pour le coup moi je les les
je les intègre et je vais pas l'intégrer
pour les autres ça déjà pas très et pas
très chouette de ne pas les reconnaître
si en plus on culpabilise l'âge mais bon
je prends déjà assez sur mes épaules
j'ai déjà ma croix à porter j'essaie
d'en parler le plus possible autour de
moi parce que souvent ça débloque
beaucoup de gens en fait il ya beaucoup
de gens qui culpabilise énormément de
pas reconnaître les gens
ou alors il ya une acquise à l'inversé
moi je peux savoir le visage leurs
maîtres dans n'importe quel contexte par
contre les noms ne viennent pas donc je
pense que c'est d'autres endroits de la
mémoire
je pense que l inverse si moi je propose
conseils j'en donne beaucoup et j'en
parle énormément pour que ça
déculpabilise et que les gens disent ah
on peut être ai je sais que deux trois
fois ça a débloqué des gens qui vont
dire que je vais me renseigner sur ce
sujet parce que peut-être que c'est ça
que j'ai et peut-être que ça va me faire
du bien de le savoir
ok cool est ce que tu veux ajouter
quelque chose
écoute moi je te reconnais très avis
merci aux deux
merci beaucoup d'humour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]